the Donald Trump cabinet confirmation
hearing Gong Show has begun I've been
watching this morning some of the jeff
Sessions attorney general confirmation
hearings a Democratic senator Elizabeth
Warren from Massachusetts was calling
for no confirmation hearings until the
ethics issues that were outstanding with
a number of Trump pics were resolved
obviously that didn't happen you'd
probably need about a decade to resolve
those ethics issues and we didn't have a
decade and of course Republicans didn't
care so let's take a look at the
schedule of hearings as as we know it
now up for today we had uh have have
been having will have will have had by
tomorrow jeff Sessions for attorney
general john kelly department of
homeland security tomorrow we've got Rex
Tillerson elaine chao and mike pompeo
schedule Betsy DeVos the education
secretary had been scheduled for
tomorrow but that's been moved to
January 17th on the 12th we will hear
from James mattis Wilbur Ross and Ben
Carson that seems to me like it'll be
the funniest day mostly because of ben
Carson but also because of some of those
other names and Tom Price tentatively
scheduled for the 18th many not yet
scheduled so some of the things I was
looking at at least with jeff sessions
today and we'll have some highlights and
clips for you tomorrow into how much
detail will the inquiring minds of the
Senators on the panel go about jeff
Sessions is racist past actually failing
to be confirmed as a judge some decades
ago and alleged the alleged comments
that if true were incredibly racist in
nature part of that lack of confirmation
also what about voting rights civil and
voting rights issues how much of a
factor would those be he's been asked
about this stuff but it's all been sort
of everybody handling it kind of like
we're just here for fun this is just a
rubber stamp it's basically business as
usual in the Senate well usually when
there's a confirmation hearing for a
sitting senator it's just kind of
formality yeah but given his record on
civil rights voting rights gay rights I
wouldn't be surprised if the Democrats
didn't let him slide so much yeah I mean
I saw pat leahy and he
asked some questions that could be
considered adversarial but then just a
simple answer from jeff Sessions like I
will enforce the law oh okay and then
and then uh Lahey just moving on uh
Republicans of course mostly talking
about what a great guy he is and
introducing into the record all of these
letters when you hear Rachel that oh I'd
like to add to the record the glowing
recommendation of some Republican
Attorney assistant attorney general in
Louisiana do you say oh wow I really
need to reconsider my views about jeff
Sessions because some Deputy Attorney
General in Louisiana thinks he's a
really nice guy but that doesn't change
my mind at all i guess the larger issue
i have here and i feel like this is kind
of commonplace with everyone that trumps
hired this kind of gross oversight on
that's basically just institutionalized
um I'm not gonna say its
institutionalized idiocracy but I'm just
this oversight of saying okay we're
going to give these lofty promotions to
unqualified individuals because we're
more concerned with giving these
promotions than the American people well
that's the entire Trump presidency I
mean went up when Trump is the president
and all of a sudden media starts doing
an analysis of cabinet pics you're
basically saying we're going to pretend
like there's anything remotely normal
about Donald Trump becoming president of
the United States and deciding who is
the top attorney in the country jeff
Sessions or who is the top intelligence
person by even talking and I feel like
we have no choice but to in a way be
victims of this by even talking about
the confirmation hearings we're buying
into the idiocracy that is Donald Trump
gets to choose who is in the cabinet
especially because there's at least two
or three cabin picks who are just
philosophically opposed yeah the
agencies that they've been chosen ben
Carson and Rick Perry among them ben
Carson more out of ignorance he just
doesn't know anything about housing and
urban development will get to that some
right-wingers no doubt I haven't read
any right-wing opinion about the jeff
Sessions confirmation hearings yet but
there's no doubt that some right-wingers
will say asking jeff Sessions about his
allegedly racist comments proves that
Democrats are actually racist for
noticing that some of the things he said
might appear to be racist there's this
reverse thing which goes on and i'm not
talking about reverse racism which is
either racism or it's not it's if you
see racism you're actually the racist
because you've noticed that race is
relevant to someone Republicans love
that stuff I mean that buys into the
pseudo were against political
correctness stuff that Trump is parotid
I think that that's just the most bogus
argument Rachel if you see racism you're
actually racist I be yeah that's a
completely bogus argument but the way
that he's trying to get around that is
emitting all of the documentation
information from when he was Attorney
General and Senator of Alabama yeah
Lindsey Graham not asking for ten
letters about jet sessions is racism to
be added to the record i'm also
interested to see what happens with ben
Carson like for example does he show up
even remotely prepared to answer
question about what his job will be that
I that I'm curious to see that because
motivational speaker and neurosurgeon
ben Carson running Housing and Urban
Development again with the only
connection we'd we were able to draw was
Trump associates black people with
cities and Carson's blackened from
Detroit so I guess maybe Trump thinks Oh
Housing and Urban Development make sense
but beyond that we've not been able to
figure out Pat unless you have what the
connection is between Carson's expertise
or lack thereof and this cabinet
position yeah he has absolutely no
qualifications to be put up for such an
important position to run Housing and
Urban Development and if you look at
some of the other pics I mean Rick Perry
for Secretary of Energy right have
another oops moment during his
confirmation hearing imagine if he
forgets to remember that he wanted the
Department of Energy eliminated and then
it's shocked at being asked about that
by Democrat I look forward to that the
funniest and saddest and scariest part
is that they're all going to get
confirmed and will start destroying the
United States we have a crisis of
cronyism which will have an impact if we
don't stop it and watching the
confirmation hearings is going to be
watching someone with a fire hose
filling the swamp that's what it is when
i watch the confirmation hearings thanks
for watching this video before you watch
the next one remember we're raising
money to expand the david pakman show
big league as well as expand progress
activism go to david pakman.com slash
donate donations of any size are much
appreciated